bonsoir
bien mes chers concitoyens mesdames et
messieurs je vous retrouve donc en ce
début d'année et 2021 pour vous
entretenir une nouvelle fois avec le
ministre des solidarités de la santé de
la crise sanitaire qui dure depuis
maintenant dix mois
c'est aussi pour moi l'occasion de
présenter à chacune et chacun d'entre
vous mes voeux les plus sincères pour
cette année nouvelle
avec évidemment une pensée toute
particulière pour toutes celles et ceux
qui ont subi les affres de cette
pandémie
les familles et les proches de ceux qui
en sont morts celles et ceux qui ont été
malades parfois gravement et le très
grand nombre d'entre vous qui avaient
été affectées directement ou
indirectement dans votre emploi dans
votre activité dans votre vie
quotidienne familiale ou sociale dans
votre équilibre personnel c'est à dire
quasiment la nation tout entière un
moment très difficile de notre histoire
dont j'ai une conscience aiguë des
situations parfois dramatiques
auxquelles nous devons faire face avec
courage avec détermination et avec
humanité 2021 sera l'année de
l'espérance notamment grâce à la
campagne de vaccination sur laquelle
nous reviendrons longuement mais il me
faut préalablement vous présentez d'un
situation sanitaire
aujourd'hui de notre pays même si le
virus circule légèrement moins en france
que chez la plupart de nos voisins
la situation est loin d'être revenue à
la normale le niveau des contaminations
dans notre pays reste élevé il a même
tendance à progresser depuis la mi
décembre nous étions alors à en moyenne
à 10 me de contamination par jour
nous sommes aujourd'hui un peu au dessus
des 15 mille cas quotidiens soit trois
fois plus que l'objectif vous en
souvenez de 5000 cas par jour que nous
nous étions fixés
certes c'est beaucoup moins que les 50
mille cas par jour que nous avions
enregistré fin octobre au moment du
deuxième confinement
certes la circulation du virus reste
moins actif chez nous que dans la
plupart de nos voisins européens ou les
mesures de confinement ont été
renforcées ces dernières semaines et
même ces derniers jours au royaume uni
le nombre de nouveaux cas explose depuis
quelques semaines avec un taux
d'incidence près de huit fois supérieur
au nôtre
les poussins 1re confinement total
jusqu'en mars
la suisse qui avait été peu frappée par
la première vague à un taux d'incidence
et un taux de mortalité deux fois
supérieur au nôtre
l'allemagne qui a un taux de positivité
des tests près de deux fois supérieure à
la france a dû se résoudre à un
confinement pour casser cette courbe
notre situation actuelle est sans nul
doute la conséquence des mesures de
confinement que nous avons prises au bon
moment dès la fin octobre et qui ont eu
un réel impact avec le couvre-feu cela
tient certainement aussi au sens des
responsabilités dont nous avons fait
collectivement preuve au moment des
fêtes de fin d'année ce n'est toutefois
que la semaine prochaine que nous aurons
suffisamment de recul pour en apprécier
les effets et nous resterons très
attentifs à l'évolution dans les jours à
venir car je le disais la situation
sanitaire de notre pays n'est pas revenu
à la norme
elle est même devenue plus fragile au
cours des dernières semaines
nous observons ainsi une pression sur
notre système hospitalier qui reste très
forte
chaque jour nous enregistrons près de
deux mille cinq cents nouvelles
hospitalisations et plus de 200
admission en réanimation
soit une personne toutes les 7 minutes
et cette pression ne s'est pas réduite
au cours du dernier mois
nous sommes toujours à plus de 25000
personnes hospitalisées dont 2600
malades en réanimation
un lit de réanimation sur deux est
occupé par un malade de l'aco vide pour
les accueillir
nous devons faire de la place en
continuant à des programmes
des opérations chirurgicales moins
urgente
il est donc hors de question de désarmer
notre système hospitalier
nous constatons également que la
situation se dégrade dans certains
territoires plus rapidement qu'ailleurs
c'est le cas dans les régions situées à
l'est du pays
ce qui nous a conduits à prendre la
semaine dernière des mesures spécifiques
dans 15 départements
c'est aussi le cas de certains
territoires d'outre-mer notamment la
guyane à cela s'ajoute l'inquiétude liée
à l'évolution de la situation au royaume
uni la flambée de cas que connaît ce
pays et dont je vous parlais à l'instant
pourrait être dû à l'apparition d'une
souche variante du virus
un autre est également apparu en afrique
du sud
si ces nouvelles souches virales semble
être encore peu répandue dans notre pays
elle pourrait selon les connaissances
scientifiques encore préliminaires dont
nous disposons être davantage
contagieuse compte tenu de ces éléments
et du degré d'incertitude encore élevé
nous avons immédiatement réagi pour
empêcher le plus possible que ces virus
depuis se propager sur notre territoire
nous avons décidé le 20 décembre dernier
de fermer les frontières avec le royaume
uni et cette mesure sera prolongée
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
seules certaines catégories de personnes
très précises sont autorisées elles
doivent obligatoirement présenter à un
test négatif réalisés sur le territoire
britannique pour rentrer sur notre
territoire
je cède la parole au ministre de la
santé olivier ferrand qui va vous
présenter les informations qui sont à
notre disposition sur ces deux souches
virales effectivement monsieur le
premier ministre si un virus comme le
colis de 19 est amené à muter
régulièrement
deux variantes ce virus issu de mutation
repéré au royaume uni et en afrique du
sud nous inquiète et nous mobilise en
particulier le variant sud africain est
encore mal connue il fait l'objet de
recherches à l'échelle mondiale nos
techniques de génétiques ont permis à ce
jour de le repérer chez trois patients
sur le territoire national le variant
anglais lui fait l'objet de davantage
d'études connu et de publication est ce
que nous savons où suspectons à date sur
ce variant anglais je vais le résumé
d'abord il est considéré comme plus
contagieux de l'ordre de 40 jusqu'à 70%
plus contagieux que le variant que nous
connaissons en france
deuxièmement en environ deux mois il est
devenu le variant majoritaire en
angleterre c'est à dire qu'il a pris la
place du variant tels que l'angleterre
le connaissait et qui le variant
actuellement en diffusion en france
troisièmement parce qu'il est plus
contagieux il est responsable d'une
aggravation importante de l'épidémie en
angleterre je rappelle par ailleurs que
l'angleterre comme l'ecosse ont décidé
d'un nouveau confinement
quatrièmement il donnerait le même type
de symptômes que le variant classique
sans davantage de cas graves
mais comme il est plus contagieux
forcément les cas symptomatiques et donc
les cas graves sont également plus
nombreux cinquièmement il serait plus
contagieux également chez les enfants
après certaines études préliminaires
mais il ne serait pas plus grave chez
l'enfant que le virus que nous
connaissons fort heureusement nous
voulons éviter à tout prix
la diffusion de ce variant en france à
ce jour nous avons identifié 19 cas en
circulation sur le territoire national
dont deux dans le cadre de clusters dits
à risque un en ile de france est un
en bretagne nous nous attendons
clairement à en identifier davantage
voici ce que nous mettons en place pour
pouvoir être particulièrement vigilants
et actifs
d'abord tous les laboratoires mais aussi
des centres de recherche et bien sûr
santé publique france sont mobilisés
pour traquer le variant partout
ce jeudi et demain tous les tests pcr
douteuse c'est à dire pouvant suggérer
qu'il s'agit d'un cas de variants
anglais seront analysés sur nos
plateformes pour ce qu'on appelle du
séquençage génétique permettant de
dénombrer le nombre précis de cas de
variants à date sur le territoire
national pour la journée donc
d'aujourd'hui et de demain
deuxièmement une surveillance accrue est
organisé dans les écoles en lien avec
jean michel blanquer ainsi que des
opérations de dépistage
troisièmement toute personne venant de
grande-bretagne mais également d'afrique
du sud doit présenter le résultat d'un
test négatif datant de moins de 72
heures avant le départ
s'ils souhaitent venir en france nous
prenons la menace de ce variant anglais
et la menace de ce variant sud africain
très au sérieux et nous prendrons toutes
les mesures qui s'imposeront si ces
variants devait s'avérer est diffusé sur
le territoire national merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre
face à cette situation donc fragile il
n'est donc pas question que nous
baissions lagarde dans les semaines à
venir nous devons non seulement
maintenir les mesures en vigueur visant
à freiner la circulation du virus mais
être prêt je le dis à les renforcer
dès l'instant où cela s'avérait
nécessaire en fonction de l'évolution
des prochains jours et des prochaines
semaines la situation relativement
maîtrisée de l'épidémie en france doit
en effet pas nous induire en erreur la
deuxième vague est toujours là nous
sommes loin de l'objectif des 5000 cas
par jour qui correspond au seuil de
maîtrise de l'épidémie
la pression sur notre système de santé
restent élevés et nous ne sommes
toujours pas sorti d'affaires nous
devons retrouver une dynamique de baisse
c'est la condition pour reprendre le
contrôle de l'épidémie
pour y parvenir cela me conduit à
arrêter les dispositions suivantes
premièrement toutes les activités tous
les établissements tous les équipements
qui sont aujourd'hui fermées et le
resteront encore jusqu'à la fin de ce
mois les musées les cinémas les théâtres
les salles de spectacle les équipements
sportifs ou de loisirs ne connaîtront
dans les semaines qui viennent
aucun assouplissement nous avions fixé
s'agissant du secteur de la culture avec
roselyne bachelot un point de revoyure
début janvier la situation sanitaire que
je viens de vous décrire ne nous permet
malheureusement aucune évolution
aujourd'hui les conditions d'une reprise
à compter de début février seront ainsi
concerter avec les représentants de ces
secteurs que j'ai rencontré à la fin
d'année dernière
nous souhaitons leur donner de la
visibilité en travaillant avec eux à
l'élaboration d'une méthode d'ouverture
encadré et progressive nous ferons un
point le 20 janvier prochain afin
d'examiner alors en fonction de la
situation sanitaire
s'il est possible de confirmer la
possibilité et les conditions d'une
reprise de l'activité à partir de début
février
nous avons conscience qu'à situation est
aujourd'hui très difficile pour les
artistes et les professionnels de la
culture et la ministre est totalement
engagé et déterminé à leurs côtés il en
va de même du secteur sportif que nous
accompagnons fortement avec les
ministres concernés les mêmes
considérations me conduisent à prendre
la même décision pour les stations de
ski dans les remontées mécaniques ne
pourront pas ouvrir tout de suite je
comprends là encore l'inquiétude des
élus et des professionnels de la
montagne je sais combien ils ont besoin
de visibilité notamment sur la
possibilité d'ouvrir pendant les
vacances de février
c'est vital pour ces territoires pour
lesquels cette activité saisonnière fait
vivre des familles entières toute
l'année c'est un objectif que nous
pouvons nous fixer mais il serait
prématuré de prendre une décision
aujourd'hui compte tenu des incertitudes
sanitaires qui demeure là encore nous
ferons un point le 20 janvier
à deux semaines du début des vacances
scolaires
l'état continuera donc d'accompagner les
acteurs économiques et les territoires
de montagne
il poursuivra également son action
diplomatique visent
vis des pays voisins dotés de stations
de sports d'hiver
nous ferons également ce point de
situation avec les restaurateurs des
propriétaires de bars et des salles de
sport pour qui malheureusement la
perspective d'une réouverture en janvier
n'est pas réaliste et sera d'ores et
déjà reporté à minima jusqu'à mi-février
bien évidemment pendant toute cette
période de fermeture ou d'activité
limitée le gouvernement continuera à
soutenir économiquement l'ensemble des
secteurs et les acteurs qui sont
impactées directement par nos mesures
qu'il s'agisse du recours à l'activité
partielle aux prêts garantis au fonds de
solidarité rénové aux différentes aides
sectorielles tous nos dispositifs seront
maintenus dans les mêmes conditions et
les ministres compétents seront chargés
de rencontrer des filières concernées
pour examiner d'éventuels besoins
d'accompagnement complémentaires
notamment pour ceux des secteurs qui
sont fermés sur une très longue durée
pour les aides au titre du mois de
décembre le formulaire sera mis en ligne
sur le site impots.gouv.fr
dès le 15 janvier jusqu'au 20 janvier
également nous prolongeons le régime de
couvre-feu à 20 heures depuis samedi
dernier je le disais tout à l'heure il a
été avancé à 18h dans 15 départements
nous avons observé une reprise
particulièrement sensible de la
circulation virale avec un taux
d'incidence de plus de 200 cas pour
100000 habitants
cette mesure s'appliquera au moins 15
jours
les derniers chiffres nous amène à
identifier dix départements
supplémentaires plutôt situés dans l'est
de la france où pourraient également se
poser la question d'une mise en oeuvre
de ce couvre-feu avancé comme nous
l'avons fait la semaine dernière les
préfets vont conduire très rapidement
les concertations nécessaires avec les
élus de ces territoires
pour bien analyser la situation et en
fonction de l'heure
pour des décisions seront prises d'ici
demain soir pour entrer en vigueur à
compter de dimanche
l'ensemble des dispositions que je viens
d'énoncer sont nécessaires mais je ne
peux exclure que nous ayons à prendre
des mesures nationales supplémentaires
si nous faisons le constat dans les
prochains jours que nous en avons besoin
je souhaite évidemment que nous
puissions l'éviter mais comme beaucoup
de pays qui viennent de prendre de
telles mesures récemment nous devrons
réagir vite
si nous faisons le constat d'une
nouvelle accélération du virus ainsi la
forte présence de l'épidémie les
conditions climatiques actuelles et à
venir nous rappellent que malgré les
perspectives de la vaccination
nous ne devons pas baisser la garde nous
devons maintenir des mesures de freinage
continuer à toujours respecter les
mesures barrières
nous devons également poursuivre et
renforcer notre stratégie tester alerté
protéger nous avons aujourd'hui en
france un dispositif de dépistage
particulièrement développée je vous
rappelle qu'il repose sur la gratuité
les tests sont totalement gratuits en
france pour tout le monde
c'est unique en europe pour une
personnes asymptomatiques souhaitant se
faire tester
il faut ainsi débourser près de 100
euros en allemagne ou en espagne jusqu'à
350 euros au royaume uni et même être
tiré au sort en grèce en france chacun
peut se faire tester à côté de chez lui
dans son laboratoire g100 pharmaciens
chez son médecin dans un cabinet
infirmier même chez son dentiste
on compte plus de 12000 points de tests
en france
notre dispositif était calibré en mai
dernier pour sept cent mille tests par
semaine nous l'avons porté à 1 millions
par semaine en septembre 2 millions en
novembre et pendant la semaine précédant
noël
nous avons réalisé trois millions et
demi de tests sans augmentation des
délais d'attentes
c'est plus que tout autre pays en europe
depuis mais nous n'avons pas eu de cesse
d'optimiser notre politique de dépistage
afin d'améliorer le délai de prise de
rendez vous et de rendu des tests nous
n'avons jamais caché nos difficultés en
septembre dernier lorsque les délais ce
sont allongés sous l'effet de
l'accélération de la demande
nous les avons précisément identifiés y
avons apporté des réponses de telle
sorte qu'aujourd'hui 86% des résultats
sont rendus à moins de 24 heures
c'est une réussite dont nous pouvons
être fiers et je salue toutes les
personnes qui y contribuent au quotidien
d'autres améliorations sont nécessaires
pour gagner en efficacité et mieux
garantir l'effectivité de l' isolement
des personnes positives et de leurs cas
contacts
cela passera par des outils et des
moyens nouveaux
à partir du 10 janvier dès que vous avez
des symptômes ou que vous n'êtes qu'à
contacter il vous suffira de vous
inscrire sur le site de l'assurance
maladie pour obtenir un arrêt de travail
immédiat indemnisé sans jour de carence
la scène de l'assurance-maladie
procédera à un suivi systématique avec
deux à trois appels téléphoniques sur
sept jours chaque personne déclarée
positive se verra proposer à compter du
20 janvier une visite à domicile par un
infirmier mais nous pouvons désormais
compter sur une arme encore plus
puissante
le vaccin qui constitue notre principale
source d'espoir pour sortir de cette
crise la campagne vaccinale contre la
corrida commencé le 27 décembre dernier
va se poursuivre dans les mois à venir
elle suscite des attentes qui sont
légitimes mais aussi des interrogations
qui le sont tout autant
en revanche elle a donné lieu ces
derniers jours de la part de certains à
des propos et des critiques parfois
outrancier oui c'est vrai notre propre
de vaccination a démarré plus lentement
que dans d'autres pays ce décalage
s'explique par notre choix de respecter
les principes et de priorités qui nous
ont été fixées par la haute autorité de
santé
ces principes ce calendrier ses
priorités avaient été annoncées partager
concerter avec les professionnels de
santé
avec des associations d'élus au cours de
nombreuses réunions y compris à mon
niveau
ils vous avaient été présentés ici même
le 2 décembre dernier ils ont été
détaillées devant le parlement les 15 et
16 10 ans je souhaite vous en rappeler
les fondements et les objectifs vous
présenter aussi l'organisation que nous
avons retenu pour un assuré le
déploiement mais aussi les dispositions
que nous avons prises pour accélérer la
mise en oeuvre
car oui en effet comme l'a souhaité le
président de la république nous devons
gagner du temps et aller plus vite
premier principe tous ceux qui le
souhaitent doivent pouvoir accéder aux
vaccins
le faire sur la base du volontariat
évidemment de manière gratuite et dans
le respect de garanties strictes en
matière de recueil du consentement et de
surveillance les éventuels effets
indésirables
deuxième élément clé pour répondre à cet
engagement
la france a pré commandé plus de 200
millions de vaccins qui nous seront
livrés tout au long de l'année 2021
je vous rappelle que nous avons avec nos
partenaires européens pré commander
depuis juin dernier
tous les vaccins les plus prometteurs et
je veux être clair que c'était le seul
mécanisme de nature à garantir le plus
grand nombre de doses pour nos
concitoyens
au vu de la saturation actuelle du
marché il nous a déjà permis de
constituer un portefeuille très large de
vaccins en cours de développement nous
en avons même commandé beaucoup plus que
nécessaire pourquoi car il est possible
que certains de ces vaccins n'obtiennent
pas les autorisations ou les obtiennent
plus tard qu'annoncé
cela ne dépend pas de nous et nous avons
donc pris des marges de sécurité pour ne
pas être en pénurie
la ministre en charge du dossier agnès
pannier rue nash et pourra tout à leur
répondre à vos questions sur ce sujet
pour autant cela signifie que tout le
monde pourra pas être vaccinés tout de
suite en france comme ailleurs
notre objectif est donc clair et il a
toujours été vaccinées en priorité le
plus vite possible les 15 millions de
personnes âgées et souffrant de pato
logis chronique pourquoi parce que les
premiers vaccins qui arrive permettent
surtout de prévenir quand on attrape là
que vit de développer une forme grave de
la maladie
cela veut donc dire qu'il faut protéger
celles et ceux qui sont les plus à
risque d'être hospitalisé voire de
décéder c'est à dire les 15 millions de
personnes âgées ou atteintes d'une
pathologie chronique
si nous parvenons à vacciner ces 15
millions de personnes nous les aurons
protéger du risque sanitaire et nous
aurons protéger nos hôpitaux
nous avons bon espoir que d'autres
vaccins obtiennent dans les semaines à
venir les autorisations nécessaires pour
que nous puissions bénéficier de
davantage de doses et donc de vacciner
davantage de personnes encore d'ici
l'été
après court terme d'ici fin janvier les
quantités reçues et qui arrive au cours
du mois nous permettant d'être en
capacité de vacciner au moins un million
de personnes soit le même nombre que nos
voisins européens au prorata de notre
population
ce rythme est celui des capacités
industrielles qui sont aujourd'hui en
forte tension
nous veillerons à acheminer des doses de
vaccin sur l'ensemble du territoire
national y compris dans les départements
d'outre-mer troisième élément clé
la haute autorité de santé nous a
demandé de démarrer la vaccination par
les personnes un ehpad et à l'unité de
soins de longue durée car ce sont elles
qui ont payé le plus lourd tribut à la
crise
si elles ne représentent que 1% de la
population elles représentent un tiers
des morts de la cour id même si cela est
plus long même si cela est plus
difficile d'aller vacciner ces personnes
et que cela ne permet pas immédiatement
de faire du chiffre il est indispensable
de le faire cette première phase est
également ouverte aux personnes en
situation de handicap vulnérables qui
sont hébergées en maison d'accueil
spécialisée et en foyer d'accueil
médicalisé
c'est un impératif sanitaire et c'est un
impératif éthique et ce choix des ehpad
explique très largement le démarrage
très progressive des premiers jours
chacun peut en effet entendre qu'on ne
recueille pas le consentement d'une
personne de 90 ans atteinte de la
maladie d'alzheimer comme on le ferait
pour un jeune de 20 ans nous voulons
faire des choses bien dans le respect de
ces personnes en présence de leur
médecin traitant avec l'accord de leurs
familles ce sont les directeurs d'ehpad
des professionnels de santé les
associations de patients qui nous ont
demandé de leur laisser le temps
d'organiser cela les vaccinations à
nepad ont démarré depuis le 27 décembre
et s'accéléreront comme prévu dans les
prochains jours jusqu'à fin janvier
début février
j'ai demandé à madame lasserre qui est
directrice de l'ehpad pari de venir nous
présenter vous présentez vous expliquer
la manière dont se passe concrètement la
préparation de nepad à la vaccination
merci madame monsieur premier ministre
merci de me donner la parole je suis
devant vous en qualité de directrice
d'un ehpad qui accueille 94 personnes en
grande majorité des personnes âgées
vulnérables en perte d'autonomie
polypathologiques est pour beaucoup
atteints de maladies neuro évolutive et
je viens vous faire partager mon
expérience de terrain
comme beaucoup d'autres établissements
notre établissement a été fortement
touchée lors de la première vague du coc
vide un tiers de nos résidents ont été
atteints
9 ans sont décédés et 23 collaborateurs
ont été infectées et je tiens ici à
rendent hommage à toutes les familles
qui ont été frappés par cette pandémie
depuis près d'un an nous avons lutté
avec tous les moyens dont nous
disposions modifier les protocoles et
adapter notre organisation afin de
limiter au maximum l'impact du virus et
l'arrivée de ce vaccin est une vraie
source d'espoir pour tous pour nos
résidents pour leurs proches et pour
toutes nos équipes depuis le 23 décembre
20 dates de la publication de l'avis de
la has nous sommes pleinement mobilisés
pour mettre en oeuvre la vaccination
conformément à la stratégie définie par
le gouvernement avec l'appui des
services supports pour ma part 2 de mon
groupe à cppa nous avons établi des lits
et des communications régulières avec
les résidents les familles et nous les
représentants légaux qui ont permis de
recenser les 20 premiers volontaires
dans mon ehpad en lien avec notre
médecin coordonnateur les médecins
traitants se sont mobilisés pour
réaliser les visites près vaccinale
recueillir les consentements et lorsque
cela était nécessaire prendre l'avis des
proches ou des représentants légaux sans
cadre formel mais le médecin faisant le
lien avec le dossier médical de son
patient cette première phase fait des
changes et d'information est essentielle
et nous y consacrons tout le temps
nécessaire
elle se déroule dans le respect des
personnes que nous accueillons celui de
leurs droits et selon le principe
déontologique du libre choix
cette temporalité nous permet de mener
cette campagne dans un climat empreint
de confiance et de sérénité en amont
s'étendent échanges entre résidents
familles et soignants s'avère important
et très positif et je peux témoigner que
souvent ils permettent de lever les
doutes et d'évacuer les inquiétudes
ainsi une de nos résidentes par exemple
était totalement réfractaires à la
vaccination dans un premier temps est si
rallye après un cheminement au cours
duquel elle a pu poser toutes les
questions nécessaires à une prise de
décision éclairée
elle a également pu partager du ce temps
de réflexion avec sa famille sur ce
point il est à noter que beaucoup de
familles nous contactent spontanément
par téléphone ou par courriel pour mieux
s'informer et pour nous faire part de
leurs souhaits en lien avec l'agencé
régionale de santé et l'ap-hp
l'acheminement des doses de vaccin sera
organisée avec la coopération de notre
pharmacien d'officine de ville ce qui
permet de garantir le strict respect des
protocoles et de la chaîne du froid
de même comme dans cette première phase
pilote nos résidents qu'ils souhaitent
seront vaccinés par groupes de cinq
ils bénéficieront d'une surveillance
rapprochée pendant une trentaine de
minutes autour d'un potager dans un
esprit de convivialité des ans - et
compte tenu de la fragilité plus grande
de certains l'équipe médicale et
paramédicale restera vigilante et
assurera un accompagnement ainsi qu une
attention renforcée pendant 48 heures à
ce jour les 20 premiers
donc qui ont été vaccinés lors de la
première phase pilote le 30 décembre
dernier se porte parfaitement bien
tous ont exprimé leur satisfaction du
déroulé de l'événement ainsi que des
modalités de suivi et ils sont désormais
nos meilleurs ambassadeurs
leurs témoignages rassurants ont été de
nature à encourager le passage à l'acte
de nombreux de nos co résidents et
aujourd'hui trente résidants ont déjà
passé une visite médicale et ont fait
part de leur souhait de recevoir ce
vaccin
le 18 janvier prochain par ailleurs nos
collaborateurs sont également de plus en
plus nombreux à avoir donné leur accord
comme les 700 les 7000 autres ehpad de
france on va poursuivre cette campagne
qui pour nous est porteuse vraiment de
tant d'espoirs et nous sommes prêts
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup madame
comment comme le président de la
république nous l'a demandé à aller
encore plus vite
il ne s'agit pas de modifier comme je
lai entendu ici ou là notre stratégie
mais il s'agit par tous moyens
d'anticiper d'optimiser de simplifier sa
mise en oeuvre et son déploiement
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé
d'avancer ce que nous appelons la phase
2 de notre stratégie vaccinale
après les ehpad qui ne devait démarrer
qu'en février et cela dans trois
directions première évolution les
professionnels de santé et les aides à
domicile de plus de 50 ans peuvent se
faire vacciner depuis lundi au total ce
sont déjà plus de 45000 personnes qui
ont été vaccinées au cours des cinq
derniers jours deuxième évolution les
personnes de plus de 75 ans pourront se
faire vacciner à partir de lundi 18
janvier ces vaccinations se dérouleront
dans des centres de vaccination un
centre par département a déjà été
ouverts donc sans sur le territoire à
partir de lundi prochain
il y en aura trois cents puis six ans
progressivement jusqu'à la fin du mois
de janvier
j'ai par ailleurs décidé que le
déploiement de la stratégie vaccinale
dans les territoires s'effectuera selon
les principes suivants les directeurs
généraux des ars les préfets de région
sont les garants
déploiement de la stratégie vaccinale de
sa transparence et du respect de ses
règles éthiques
les préfets de département avec l'appui
des délégués territoriaux de la rs
seront les patrons un pilote par
département des opérations logistiques
de vaccination ils impliqueront le
maximum de professionnels de santé dans
le cadre des structures existantes
médecins infirmiers pharmaciens que ces
derniers soient libéraux ou un
établissement avec mobilisation possible
des retraités ils travailleront avec les
élus locaux les maires en particulier
parce que c'est un sujet de proximité et
les présidents d'agglomération au siège
des centres de vaccination
tous ces élus qui ont et je les en
remercie pour beaucoup fait d'ores et
déjà acte de candidature pour contribuer
à cette formidable opération évidemment
les organisations retenues pour en
varier selon les départements et les
territoires je fais confiance aux
acteurs des territoires
parallèlement nous simplifiant les
démarches les différentes étapes qui
avait été prévu pour les personnes très
vulnérables
un ehpad et que vous a rappelé madame la
directrice et en décembre quand nous
avions encore peu de recul sur le vaccin
seront allégées pour les populations
moins fragiles ou se faire vacciner
comment prendre rendez vous quelles sont
les démarches à entreprendre
le ministre de la santé va maintenant
vous donner davantage de précisions
nous mettons tout en oeuvre pour vous
permettre de vous faire vacciner dans de
bonnes conditions
il ya 48 heures j'ai annoncé que nous
disposions désormais de suffisamment de
garanties retour d'expérience mais aussi
recommandations pour pouvoir amplifier
accélérer et simplifier notre stratégie
vaccinale les retours d'expérience ce
sont ces millions d'humains désormais
vaccinés de par le monde
le vaccin est sûr les effets
indésirables graves sont extrêmement
rares on nous dit d'après les premières
remontées mais qui sont consolidées jour
après jour de l'ordre d'environ un
patient pour cent mille vacciner ce sont
des événements de nature essentiellement
allergiques et qui interviennent chez
des personnes qui sont par ailleurs
connu pour être très allergique même
sans contexte de vaccination au point
que le plus souvent elles ne sortent pas
de chez elle sans avoir à quitter
d'adrénaline sur elle les garanties ce
sont les circuits logistiques qui ont
montré qu'ils étaient pleinement
opérationnel et qui font que dans chaque
département des vaccins ont été ou sont
livrés les recommandations ce sont les
autorités scientifiques et sanitaires
qui nous disent que nous pouvons
anticiper la vaccination des publics
prioritaires au delà des seuls résidents
âgées en établissement collectif
après 48 heures voici donc nos premiers
résultats
je disais amplifiés et accélérés nous
avons accéléré le rythme de livraison de
nombreux ehpad dont de nombreux
territoires
nous avons initié la vaccination des
soignants des pompiers des aides à
domicile âgé de 50 ans et plus ou
porteurs de ce qu'on appelle les
comorbidités c'est à dire des maladies
qui les expose à des risques de forme
grave
nous ouvrons également avec sophie
cluzel la vaccination aux personnes
handicapées qui vivent en établissements
spécialisés mais aussi aux personnels
qui y travaillent
s'ils sont âgés de 50 ans ou plus ou
s'ils ont eux mêmes porteurs de
comorbidité ensuite nous avons multiplié
par près de quatre le nombre d'hôpitaux
livrer un vaccin
nous avons ouvert au moins un centre de
vaccination par département et même
plusieurs centres dans bon nombre de
départements
monsieur le premier ministre vous l'avez
dit nous avons permis la vaccination
avant-hier d'environ 5000 personnes hier
c'était 12 mille cinq cents personnes
nous n'avons pas les chiffres définitifs
du jour mais ce sera au moins 25000
personnes supplémentaires vacciner
aujourd'hui avec une montée en puissance
qui va se poursuivre jour après jour
jusqu'à atteindre ce rythme de croisière
que nous voulons de plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de français vaccinés par
jour et nous visons un million de
personnes vaccinées d'ici à la fin du
mois de janvier
c'est bien c'est mieux mais vous l'avez
dit monsieur le premier ministre nous
souhaitons aller plus loin plus fort et
plus vite les autorités sanitaires
françaises viennent de valider un
principe important selon lequel il est
possible sans risque et sans perte
d'efficacité de différer la deuxième
injection du vaccin de pfizer ce qu'on
appelle un rappel vaccinal jusqu'à six
semaines au lieu de trois cela nous
permet de disposer de davantage de doses
disponibles tout de suite en tout ce
sont 1 millions 46 mille doses de vaccin
weiser dont nous disposons actuellement
- celle dont qui ont été injectés et
chaque semaine nous recevrons 500 mille
doses supplémentaires de ce vaccin et ce
jusqu'à la fin du mois de février
en mars le rythme doublera environ un
million de vaccins livrés par semaine
grâce à l'ouverture de nouvelles lignes
de production
par ailleurs un autre vaccin à arn
messagers donc le même mécanisme que le
vaccin de pfizer
celui ci s'est moderna a été autorisé
dans les mêmes conditions d'utilisation
hier par l'agencé médicale européenne du
médicament et quelque cinquante mille
premiers vaccins seront livrés dès lundi
en tout nous attendons un peu plus de
100000 vaccin pour le mois de janvier
pour modern à 500 milles supplémentaires
en février un peu plus d'un million en
mars et en avril et plus de 2 millions
en mai et en juin
enfin ce ne sont pas 1 2 3 mai six
centres de vaccination qui seront
ouverts en janvier dans chaque
département destiné à la population
c'est le choix de la proximité que nous
faisons
les français à raison d'environ donc un
centre pour 100000 habitants soit
environ dix fois plus de centres pour la
population que nombre de nos voisins
comme par exemple nos voisins allemands
le moment est donc venu de nous préparer
à élargir la liste des personnes pouvant
bénéficier de la vaccination je parle
des quelques 5 millions de français qui
sont âgés de 75 ans et plus si vous êtes
dans cette situation vous pourrez à
partir de la semaine prochaine
prendre rendez vous en vue d'être
vacciné et la vaccination pourra
commencer le 18 janvier prochain
je le dis tout de suite cette
vaccination elle sera nécessairement
progressive
elle prendra plusieurs semaines au fur
et à mesure chacun peut le comprendre
que les laboratoires nous fournirons les
doses de vaccin nous faisons en france
mais aussi à l'échelle européenne avec
agnès pannier runes haché avec clément
bonne le maximum pour sécuriser un
maximum de doses le monde entier dans la
même situation qui achètent les mêmes
vaccins et nous accompagnons les
entreprises y compris en europe
d'ailleurs pour augmenter les chaînes de
production
en pratique si vous avez 75 ans ou plus
donc qu'est ce qui va se passer
d'abord vous aurez deux moyens pour
prendre rendez vous pour vous faire
vacciner
il y aura un numéro de téléphone qui
sera communiqué prochainement qui vous
orientera dans les différents centres au
plus près de chez vous il y aura
également un site internet c'est le site
sante.fr qui vous indiquera la marche à
suivre pour vous signaler et prendre
rendez vous avec une carte interactive
vous cliquez sur votre région vous avez
la liste des centres qui apparaît et
vous pourrez prendre rendez-vous
d'ailleurs directement sur ce site
internet
nous voulons donner accès à cette ligne
téléphonique est au site internet
le jeudi prochain 14 janvier ces deux
moyens de prise de rendez-vous seront
progressivement enrichi à mesure que les
centres de vaccination seront ouverts en
supplémentaire est équipé en vaccins je
remercie d'ailleurs les ars les
préfectures les élus locaux les
soignants qui se mobilisent pour ouvrir
et faire fonctionner ces centres chaque
commune évidemment de notre territoire
national n'aura pas son propre centre ce
serait incohérent vu le nombre de doses
et de personnes à vacciner
la répartition départementale elle est
décidée en concertation avec les
services de l'état dans le cadre de
cellules territoriales amplifié accéléré
et je disais aussi simplifié j'y viens
mais d'abord je voudrais revenir sur un
certain nombre d'incompréhensions ou de
contre vérités qui ont pu circuler ces
derniers jours non il n'a jamais été
question d'exiger un consentement écrit
pour se faire vacciner
le consentement n'a pas plus de valeur
endroit que le consentement aura qu'ils
soient écrits ou qu'ils soient orale ce
qui est exigé
c'est qu'une personne qui va se faire
vacciner elle est reçue comme pour tout
acte médical une information claire
loyale et appropriée évidemment que ne
se pose qu'elle ne s'oppose pas à la
vaccination n'est par définition pas le
cas d'une personne âgée de 75 ans qui
prendrait rendez vous pour aller se
faire vacciner dans un centre mais pour
une personne âgée vulnérable et madame
la directrice d pad vous l'avez très
bien dit tout à l'heure qui n'est pas
forcément en capacité d'exprimer
d'ailleurs sa propre volonté
il faut s'assurer qu'elle ne s'y
opposent pas ou prendre le temps de
consulter la personne référente où la
famille
non il n'a jamais été question de
recueillir un consentement cinq jours
avant de vacciner
ce que nous demandons aux ehpad c'est
d'indiquer le nombre de doses que nous
devons envoyer dans cet ehpad le jour j
imaginez une seconde qu'on envoie 100
doses de vaccins dans un ehpad où il ya
100 résidents et que le jour j de la
vaccination il n'y que 40 personnes qui
acceptent ou qu'ils soient en état de se
faire vacciner
ce serait 60 doses de perdus et là ce
serait inexcusable
en pratique chaque ehpad connaît sa date
de livraison en vaccins et nous leur
demandons de faire remonter leurs
besoins précis quelques jours avant que
nous intervenions la vaccination en
ehpad a commencé progressivement elle va
prendre de l'ampleur
dès la semaine prochaine dans plusieurs
régions france entière à compter de la
semaine suivante est un délai qui
correspondait vous l'avez très bien dit
à la demande initiale des établissements
pour personnes âgées et nous travaillons
d'arrache-pied avec brigitte bourguignon
ministre délégué en charge de
l'autonomie
en revanche le recul dont nous disposons
désormais nous permet c'est vrai de
simplifier le parcours de la personne
vaccinée sans rien renier sur la
sécurité et sur la qualité
le conseil d'orientation pour la
stratégie vaccinale qui est présidé par
le professeur alain fischer nous y
encourage voici donc en pratique comment
cela va se passer si vous avez 75 ans ou
plus vous êtes d'abord libre si vous le
souhaitez d'aller consulter votre
médecin pour lui poser toutes vos
questions vérifier l'absence de
contre-indication
mais ce n'est pas une obligation vous
pouvez le faire mais vous n'y êtes pas
obligé vous vous inscrivez donc par
téléphone ou sur le site sante.fr vous
réservez votre créneau dans le centre le
plus proche de chez vous sur place un
médecin ou toutes autres soignants
d'ailleurs vous posera quelques
questions on vous fera même remplir un
auto questionnaire très simple qui
visera juste à vérifier que vous pouvez
être vaccinés normalement et dans de
bonnes conditions quelques questions je
les résume avez vous une co vide au
cours des trois derniers mois
avez vous été vaccinées contre la grippe
au cours des trois dernières semaines
souffrez-vous d'allergies graves
avez-vous de la fièvre ou d'autres
symptômes
prenez-vous certain traitement
particulier à signaler au cas où êtes
vous enceinte on est d'accord il ya peu
de risques après 75 ans mais je voudrais
être exhaustif
si vous le souhaitez vous pourrez voir
un médecin puisqu'il y aura toujours un
médecin présent sur le centre où vous
serez vacciner sinon vous pouvez
directement passer à l'étape de la
vaccination c'est à dire qu'une fois le
questionnaire rempli et validé
médicalement
vous serez invité à recevoir l'injection
du vaccin par un médecin un infirmier ou
d'ailleurs toutes autres soignants
habilité à le faire
il s'agit d'une injection
intramusculaire dans l'épaule le plus
souvent comme la plupart des vaccins
à l'issue une injection vous serez amené
à rester environ 15 minutes sur place
par mesure de sécurité et ensuite vous
pourrez rentrer chez vous vous serez
vacciner il restera à faire la même
chose entre trois et six semaines après
la première injection et vous serez donc
protégé contre les formes graves du co
lead ce que je viens de décrire ce qui
va rythmer notre campagne de vaccination
au cours des deux prochains mois une
fois encore nous ferons le maximum pour
répondre au maximum de demandes le plus
vite possible
ensuite il ya une autre phase de la
vaccination ou plutôt deux autres phases
ailleurs qui démarreront d'abord
l'ouverture aux 65 ans et plus c'est à
dire 7 millions de français
supplémentaires c'est lorsque nous
aurons suffisamment protéger les
personnes les plus fragiles les plus
vulnérables donc les personnes âgées de
75 ans et plus et puis il y aura surtout
l'arrivée d'autres vaccins au
fonctionnement différent qui auront
évidemment eux aussi été validés parce
qu'ils seront jugés sûrs et efficaces
nous espérons ces vaccins avant le mois
de mars pour certains d'entre nous
disposerons de grandes quantités qui
permettront d'aller bien plus vite et de
protéger un maximum de français
ces vaccins et en plus ils ne sont pas
conservées à -80 degré ni à moins 20
degrés ils pourront être réalisés en
ville directement auprès de vos
soignants je rappelle à titre d'exemple
que cette année pour la campagne
grippale ce sont 1,5 million de doses de
vaccins contre la grippe qui ont été
écoulés en moins de 24 heures il m'est
difficile de fixer ici un nombre de
français qui seront vaccinées à coup sûr
avant l'été vous le comprendrez parce
que ça dépend de la validation en bonne
et due forme de ces vaccins et que nous
ne pouvons pas le savoir tant que ces
vaccins n'ont pas été validés mais je
vous confirme que en tout état de cause
nous avons commandé 78 millions de doses
qui sont normalement livrés avant l'été
entre les cinq principaux vaccin c'est à
dire les deux qui existent déjà et les
trois autres
nous espérons qu'ils le seront et
évidemment c'est suspendu au fait qu'il
soit validé chaque jour nous publierons
le nombre de vaccinations quotidiennes
et cumuler un système d'information
permet aux soignants de faire remonter
tous ces chiffres au quotidien il est
opérationnel depuis lundi il nécessite
encore quelques jours pour monter en
puissance vous comprendrez que quand on
demande aux soignants d'ouvrir des
centres de vaccination d'ouvrir des
lignes de vaccination de mobiliser les
soignants pour qu'ils se fassent
vacciner
il est compliqué d'exiger d'eux que tous
les jours à la bonne heure il fasse
remonter les données mais ce sera le cas
très rapidement et vous aurez un accès
libre à ces informations et évidemment
pour l'heure nous demandons aux agences
régionales de santé de nous faire
remonter chaque soir le nombre de
vaccinations qui ont été réalisés et ce
sont les chiffres que nous vous avons
communiqué avec le premier ministre pour
conclure j'ai conscience de l'impatience
légitime de ceux qui parmi vous ont hâte
de se faire vacciner
de tout ce qu'ils voient aussi dans le
vaccin une chance de reprendre le cours
normal de leur vie retrouver leur emploi
leur université leur salle de sport le
théâtre ce ne sont pas si jours qui font
une différence face à la pandémie
ni quelques dizaines de milliers de
vacciner ce qui fera la différence c'est
notre engagement collectif dans cette
reprise en main par l'homme d'un
environnement qui était devenu
défavorable
faites vous vacciner aidez vos proches à
se faire vacciner
réaliser la chance que la science nous
offre le moment que nous vivons est
historique il connaîtra ses eaux
peut-être ses bas ses grands moments
d'engouement collectif peut-être ces
phase d'incompréhension
comme par exemple si nous devions manqué
quelques jours de vaccins entre deux
ravitaillements mais à la fin on nous
vaccinons nous sauveront des vies et
nous retrouverons la nôtre je le redis
nous mettons tout en oeuvre pour vous
permettre de vous faire vacciner dans de
bonnes conditions
merci monsieur ministre de la santé et
vous l'avez compris le déploiement de la
vaccination dessine une perspective
claire de pouvoir sortir progressivement
de cette crise sanitaire
à l'échéance nous l'espérons tous de
l'été prochain pour autant nous allons
devoir vivre avec ce virus encore
plusieurs mois
nous ne baisserons donc pas la garde sur
les gestes barrières les tests ou encore
les mesures de freinage ce serait
irresponsable
mais la vaccination est devenue la
priorité numéro 1 de l'action du
gouvernement
nous sommes tous convaincus que c'est la
vaccination la plus large la plus
massive et la plus rapide qui nous
permettra de sortir de la crise
ne confondons pas néanmoins vitesse et
précipitation les choses doivent être
faites dans le plus grand sérieux et le
plus grand respect des personnes les
plus fragiles car nous avons besoin de
l'adhésion de tous alors j'en appelle à
la sérénité
je demande que cessent les polémiques
stériles qui n'apporte rien sinon que
d'inquiéter inutilement nos concitoyens
déjà fatigué et à fleur de peau du fait
de la durée et de l'ampleur de cette
crise inédite
on ne peut pas alors que le match vient
de commencer et qu'il durera plusieurs
mois prétendent dès les premières
minutes que dis-je dès les premières
secondes qu'il ait déjà perdu
bien au contraire nous relèverons
ensemble le pari de la vaccination et
nous surmonterons ce défi historique
nous voulons à la fois permettre
l'exercice d'un véritable droit à la
vaccination
certes organisées en fonction de
priorités sanitaires et convaincre le
maximum d'entre vous précisément parce
que nous avons pris toutes les garanties
éthique et médical de se faire vacciner
se faire vacciner et c'est se protéger
soi même mais c'est aussi protéger les
autres
montrons que nous sommes une nation
solidaire une nation généreuse
j'en appelle une nouvelle fois à notre
sens des responsabilités individuelles
et collectives
mes chers concitoyens
une phase nouvelle de la lutte contre la
pandémie s'est ouverte il s'agit d'un
défi humain et logistique considérable
et inédit qui nécessite patience et
détermination et je ne doute pas de
notre succès collectif
je m'en tiens mesdames et messieurs à
votre disposition le premier ministre
toujours chemical 1 pour tf1 et lci
vous avez dit tout à l'heure prendre la
menace du variant britannique du virus
très au sérieux
l'om est ce ce matin a demandé à
l'europe d'en faire plus face à une
situation qu'elle qualifie d' allah
remonte alors la france doit-elle
justement en faire plus et comment est
ce que la piste d'une fermeture des
écoles est envisagée ou de vacances
scolaires qui duraient plus longtemps
pour enrayer la contagion de cette
souche est ce qu'un nouveau confinement
est lui aussi envisagé est ce qu'il ne
faut pas comme le disait l'un des
membres du conseil scientifique frappé
tôt efforts pour éviter de se retrouver
dans la situation anglaise merci on va
pas on va on va plus charger les en 25
ans je vais faire deux questions par
deux questions d'accord parce que le
ministre peut se préparer
bonsoir monsieur le premier ministre je
dois van aelst pour bfm tv
au vu des chiffres qui en ce début
d'année ne sont pas très satisfaisant
avec les cas on le voit qui augmente à
nouveau sommes-nous pas en train de
payer les fêtes de fin d'année et
notamment noël avec eux les nombreuses
familles françaises qui ont pu se réunir
à noël et puis deuxième deuxième
question que répondez-vous aux
différents présidents de région et chivu
qui demandent en fait de bien de
d'acheter eux-mêmes pardon d'acheter
eux-mêmes les doses de vaccin pour aller
plus vite merci
alors je le ministre voudra bien
compléter mon propos notamment par
rapport à l oms
voyez ça c'est le sel de ma fonction et
mesdames vous me dites est ce qu'on ne
paye pas les fêtes de fin d'année
notamment noël
après m'avoir accusée de sacrifier noël
vous en souvenez quand on a pris les
décisions donc un courant c'est trop et
puis les mêmes 15 jours après vous
reproche de ne pas en faire assez
sans doute que la vérité est au juste
milieu pour ceux qui en tout cas des
fêtes de fin d'année c'était la deuxième
la deuxième question comme je les dis
dans mon intervention il vous le savez
d'ailleurs pour connaître l'impact
épidémique je porte
mais sous le contrôle de mise à santé je
pense qu'il est encore un peu tôt pour
pouvoir l'apprécier de façon claire il
n'y a pas que noël je dirais sur
l'ensemble la période
donc je vous ai indiqué que le temps qui
est devant nous pour ce motif madame
votre question est très pertinente est
crucial c'est à dire voyez si on laisse
s'écouler c'est à peu près au milieu de
la semaine prochaine que nous aurons des
données consolidées les fermetures des
écoles juste olivier veyrat vous vous
répondra sur le plan sécuritaire vous me
permettrez une remarque plus générale
nous avons eu à faire face si j'ose dire
et comme le dit jean michel blanquer à
plusieurs rentrées scolaires depuis le
début de cette crise sanitaire avec un
premier confinement ou les écoles
avaient été vous vous en souvenez toutes
et tous fermés on en a tiré les
enseignements en disant vraiment que je
crois d'ailleurs c'est que c'est ce que
dit ou écrit aussi le ms ou un autre
institution que la la fermeture des
écoles devaient être envisagée vraiment
dernier recours je sais que certains
pays ont recouru ma position est que
effectivement il faut vraiment que
l'association a sanitaire soit
gravissime pour fermer des écoles car
nous savons que les conséquences y
compris
ni terres de la fermeture des écoles
sont absolument dramatiques
j'observe d'ailleurs nous suivons tous
les jours tous les jours la situation
des clusters décontamination dans les
écoles dans les collèges dans les lycées
qui je vous rappelle ont déjà vu leur
fonctionnement allégées avant les
vacances de noël nous suivons tous les
jours cette situation et la dernière
rentrée puis s'est réalisée de façon
tout à fait je le dis satisfaisante par
rapport à ce qui se passe en
grande-bretagne décision a été prise dès
que nous avons eu les premières données
de renforcer dessus la surveillance
épidémiologique et des tests dans les
écoles et le ministre aura l'occasion de
vous présenter la montée en charge de
cette politique de dépistage dans les
écoles en particulier dans les lycées et
qui est déjà comme je le disais très
élevé je termine en vous répondant sur
les présidents de région je veux dire
toutes les bonnes volontés sont
bienvenues
aucun sujet simplement la fourniture de
doses vaccinales vous le savez fait
l'objet de très fortes tensions au
niveau mondial notez bien je parle sous
le contrôle experts de manière une hache
et que les doses qui sont livrés
maintenant ont été commandés ou pré
réservés il ya de très nombreux mois et
que là nous discutons de doses
supplémentaires parce que nous cherchons
aussi à accroître les commandes et les
réponses qui nous sont faites sont
plutôt pour le quatrième trimestre de
l'année 2021 donc je je ne suis pas
certain que les régions autres
organismes
s'agissant de grosses commandes d'états
qui sont vous le savez coordonner au
sein de l'union européenne par un
certain nombre de pays
je ne suis pas certain donc cette
excellente intentions louables des
régions puissent se concrétiser à court
terme
monsieur mila santé vous avez fait une
réponse exhaustive ce premier ministre
ça va être juste dire sur cette question
de cette question des régions par
ailleurs que les régions sont associés
de façon très étroite à la concertation
sur la stratégie vaccinale depuis depuis
des semaines et des semaines lui des
communiqués certains saluaient la
qualité de la constatation et pour ne
rien vous cacher je ne vous dirai pas
qui j'ai ennuyé un 24 décembre à 20h30
en appelant pour lui parler de parler de
la stratégie vaccinale mais ça ne s'est
pas arrêtée pendant pendant les vacances
et je ne doute pas une seconde que les
plus inquiets des présidents de région
qui depuis quelques jours font valoir
leur inquiétude salueront la montée en
puissance de la vaccination dans notre
pays
puisqu'il en va de l'intérêt de la
nation que d'être soudés dans cette
période et puisque ce que nous voulons
c'est donner confiance aux français et
leur dire que nous sommes là pour les
protéger
vous avez parlé du variant anglaise j'ai
dit tout à l'heure le ce qui était mis
en oeuvre c'est à dire qu'on fait je
veux pas être rentré trop dans le détail
mais sachez que il ya plusieurs méthodes
de tests pcr c'est les thèses les
techniques de laboratoire qui permet de
faire des diagnostics
parmi ces méthodes il y en a une qui
permet de substances suspectées la
mutation anglaise ça tombe bien c'est un
tiers du parc de pc air de notre pays
donc quand on a une mutation qui est
douteuse
quand on a une pcr qui est douteuse on
l'envoie dans un labo l'a fait un
travail beaucoup plus compliqué ce qu'on
appelle un séquençage du génome du virus
qui permet d'avoir la cartographie
génétique précise du virus et de dire ça
c'est le variés anglais ou que ça
n'allait pas est ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui et demain ce que les
scientifiques font aujourd'hui et demain
c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'ils aient un
test est positif
s'il est douteux et bien ils font
séquençage s'il a été fait en sur une
pcr qui ne permet pas de dépister le le
variant il est refait sur une technique
qui permet de le dépister hélas il est
douteux et bien c'est du séquençage donc
on saura combien de cas aujourd'hui de
variants anglais étaient apparus sur
notre territoire national combien demain
ce qui nous permet d'avoir une idée de
l'état de la circulation du virus je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure 19 quatre variants
à ce stade ça vous paraît peut-être
beaucoup c'est peu par rapport aux 20
mille cas quotidiens que nous
enregistrons dans le pays
ce serait une bonne nouvelle évidemment
si c'était limite et je pense qu'il en a
plus il faut qu'on vérifie si c'est un
petit peu plus quelques dizaines ou si
c'est déjà plus le plus important
devons vraiment tout faire pour limiter
ce variant non pas parce qu'il est
anglais mais parce que il est plus
contagieux il est plus contagieux et
donc il prend le ça arrive dans toute
l'histoire des virus que vous avez un
virus qui mute et une espèce de
sélection naturelle chez virus qui fait
que plus un virus et méchant est bien
plus il va circuler à la place des
autres et nous ne voulons pas subir ce
que les anglais ont subi ils s'en sont
pas rendu compte qu'il pouvait pas le
savoir au début nous ne voulons pas que
ce variant ce virus là qui est plus
contagieux prennent la place du virus
que nous connaissons en soit nous
voulons plus du tout que les virus
circulent mais tant qu'à faire autant
éviter que ce soit le variant anglais
parce qu'il est plus contagieux y a pas
de chaos
encore une fois y avait des suspicions
des articles qui disait peut-être qu'il
est plus grave
il n'y a aucune démonstration
scientifique c'est même plutôt l'inversé
sur le fait qu'il serait plus dangereux
une fois que vous l'avez mais il est
plus contagieux et donc il faut lutter
contre merci monsieur le ministre
juste en complément ont manié voulez
vous ne devriez vous pas reconfirmer je
les dis dans mon propos tout à l'heure
la france à reconfirmer plus tôt que les
autres et ce n'est pas france expliqué
malgré tout un taux d'incidence
inquiétant mais plus bas qu'ailleurs un
taux de positivité des tests plus
favorable nous avions pris cette
décision aujourd'hui vous m'inciter à
prendre la même je rappelle recombiner
par exemple ça veut dire fermer les
commerces qui ne vendent pas des
produits de première nécessité je n'ai
pas souvenir d'avoir à l'époque reçu de
chaleureuses félicitations pour avoir
pris cette décision douloureuse
qu'aujourd'hui vous semble briller
m'inciter à décider ce qui me conduit à
vous dire que nous avons par ailleurs je
n'ai peut-être pas assez cité dans mon
propos solliciter les organismes
scientifiques pour évaluer un autre
outil qu'est le couvre feu que nous
avons gelé rappelait étendu dans son
amplitude horaire à un certain nombre de
départements 15 à ce jour et 25 à partir
de dimanche pour voir dans quelle mesure
cette ce levier si vous me passez cette
expression est efficace par rapport au
confinement pour lutter contre la
pandémie
faire reculer le taux d'incidence je
vous écoute je promets nice bonjour
thierry kurt et france 2 c'est un maire
certains élus qui souhaitent prendre des
initiatives comme par exemple ouvrir des
centres de vaccination se plaignent
d'avoir à faire un véritable mille
feuille administratif et d'avoir jusqu'à
plus d'une quinzaine d' interlocuteur
dans les différentes administrations
publiques est-ce que c'est pas là l'une
des raisons qui explique que l on soit
dans un certain nombre de blocages
est ce que vous allez simplifier ces
démarches et puis deuxième question un
certain nombre d'informations peut être
des rumeurs qui n'ont pas forcément été
vérifié je vous demande je vous pose la
question font état d'un certain nombre
de pays européens qui cherchent et qui
essayent d'acheter en parallèle un
certain nombre de doses vaccinales
est ce que c'est le cas est-ce que vous
avez des informations à ce sujet alors
on va d'abord je vais on va faire une
par une donc ça va me donner l'occasion
de faire venir je vous remercie de votre
élégance monsieur de faire venir ma
bannière une hache et au pupitre puisque
vous avez pour se poser une question sur
les approvisionnements en europe vous
avez mangé répond directement à la
question sur sur des mers parce que vous
comprendrez que c'est un sujet que que
j'affectionne particulièrement donc on
est bien d'accord la priorité du jour du
début comme on l'a toujours dit c'est
des ehpad des mères peuvent être j'en
fus résidents d'établissements
hébergeant des ehpad bien mais là c'est
un circuit très dédié un centre de
vaccination en tout cas je suppose que
c'est votre question quelque chose où
les gens sera en ne va pas faire sortir
les résidents des ehpad pour aller dans
les centres de vaccination il faut aller
vers le ton qu'on est déjà dans une
étape ultérieure que j'ai longuement
évoquée puisque j'ai parlé de ces
centres de vaccination et je vous
confirme pour à nouveau les saluer que
beaucoup de maires se porte candidat
pour épauler l'état et c'est très
heureux dans
le déploiement de la vaccination donc on
leur répond entrailles et je pense avoir
été très clair monsieur je le répète
peut-être un écho à vos interrogations
en tout cas à celle que vous relayer le
patron du déploiement de la stratégie
vaccinale au nom de l'état avec l'
agence régionale de santé
c'est le préfet de département ya un
pilote dans l'avion et je savais j'ai
souvent parlé du couple maire préfet
s'est pas première fois les maires ils
connaissent le préfet de département
sont des gens pragmatiques qu'ils savent
faire
en fait le pari de la confiance ils vont
travailler ensemble et vous verrez
progressivement alors évidemment ce jeu
je vous fais toute confiance au dessus
ici ou là il y aura sûrement un loupé en
rater ça je ne doute pas que nous
pourrons le corriger car il ne sera pas
passer sous silence
ça c'est la certitude que j'ai madame la
ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le premier
ministre peut être remettre en
perspective comment se sont déroulées
ces achats de doses vaccinales au niveau
européen les quantités dont on parle
que ce soit pour moderna pour kaiser
pour sanofi puisqu'on a parlé aussi de
ce vaccin pour jansen et pour
astrazeneca ont été sécurisés entre juin
et septembre
les quantités c'est à dire que dans
chaque cas il ya eu des pré accord qui
ensuite ont donné lieu à des contrats
plus longs dans lesquels un certain
nombre de clauses était discutée mais
les quantités elles ont été verrouillés
il y a entre 6 et ou même sept et cinq
mois et c'est ces quantités aujourd'hui
qui sont livrés avec des capacités
industrielles vous disiez sous forte
tension on peut même considérer qu'elles
sont saturés et notre travail consiste à
faire en sorte d'accompagner la montée
en puissance de ses capacités
industrielles
mais un transfert technologique d'une
je dirais d'un laboratoire
pharmaceutique vers un sous traitant
ça prend 12 mois à 18 mois en temps
normal
donc nous sommes face à une prouesse
industrielle ou de manière générale
chacun pousse les plus gros sites de son
pays pour pouvoir fabriquer le maximum
de doses donc ce qui est négocié
aujourd'hui vers les nouveaux apports
comme l'a dit monsieur le premier
ministre
ce sont des quantités qui arriveront au
deuxième semestre voire en fin de
deuxième semestre pour des raisons
évidentes de montée en puissance des
capacités industrielles et au niveau
européen
je ne lis pas dans le marc de café je ne
sais pas ce qui se passe dans l'arrière
boutique de chacun des états mais tel
qu'il est conçu de telle que sont conçus
les contrats il n'est pas matériellement
possible de livrer à la fois les
contractuels et de donner des deux en
plus c'est pas de la boulangerie et des
baguettes que nous fabriquons c'est des
vaccins et donc ça demande un minimum
d'homologation de sites de transfert
technologique de conditions rigoureuses
de monter en puissance et encore une
fois je crois qu'il faut saluer
l'exploit industriel qui a été réalisé
après l'exploit de recherche et
développement par les différents
laboratoires pharmaceutiques et comme
vous l'avez vu ils courent tous aussi
vite que possible et nous notre travail
c'est de faire en sorte qu'on fabrique
et je voulais signaler qu'il y a trois
sites en france qui vont fabriquer des
vaccins donnés dans les prochaines
semaines donc ils sont en train de
monter en puissance
recife armes pour le vaccin moderna
delpharm pour le vaccin
bayod ntech et si le vaccin curve ac est
effectivement validé fareva avec
produira ce vaccin au delà effectivement
des sites de sanofi il faut peut-être
ajouter monsieur que
notre position est très claire le plan
d'eau république l'a rappelé dans le
cadre de cette organisation et de cette
discipline européenne
nous entendons respecter parce que la
paire du permis d'avoir des précommandes
en quantité très élevée et à des à des
prix satisfaisants si des doses
vaccinales se trouve être disponible
l'instruction est clair la france
achètera tout de suite d'accord j'ai
peut-être une précision effectivement
c'est à dire que il y à un moment où
chaque pays et réinterrogé sur voulez
vous prendre votre quota populationnelle
ou pas et donc vous avez des pays qui
ont décidé de pas nécessairement prendre
la totalité de leurs quotas
populationnelle pour des raisons qui
leur appartient notamment des soucis de
logistique notamment des soucis de
distribution peu importe des soucis
budgétaires peu importe
et dans ce cas là les doses sont remis
en jeu et chacun des pays ont la
capacité à redemander dès 12 donc c'est
comme ça que ça se passe et ça peut
expliquer que vous n'ayez pas toujours
une réplication linéaire du
populationnelle mais parce qu'il ya un
premier tour et un deuxième tour et que
certains pays ont renoncé à prendre des
douze monsieur morel
monsieur le premier ministre je voulais
justement vous interroger sur ce sujet
est-ce que c'est à dire donc et qu'il
n'y aura pas nécessité de transférer en
tout cas d' inciter les industriels à
donner des licences à d'autres
industriels et on vous écoute on est ce
que ces vaccins sont fabriqués et seront
donc vous dites fabriqué en france pas
nécessairement envoyer du pays
producteurs enfin il faudrait peut-être
préciser monsieur le premier ministre je
voulais vous poser une question vraiment
beaucoup plus général est ce que vous
n'avez pas le sentiment que la polémique
est que nous avons connue sur la
vaccination a peut-être incité ou vous a
peut-être fait nous a peut-être fait
prendre conscience que les français
avaient finalement envie de se faire
vacciner que c'était peut-être un grand
changement psychologique que nous
découvrons chez nos compatriotes
mais en fait la question principale
était laissée à chaque fois quand il ya
des polémiques quand celui-ci des envies
7 effectuant très heureux madame la
ministre
oui alors dans la négociation que nous
avons menées avec les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
nous avons veillé à ce qu'il y ait des
chaînes de production en europe ses
chaînes de production elles sont pour le
dire très simplement constitué de deux
étapes une première étape pour vous
fabriquer le principe actif ou drac
substence et une deuxième étape où vous
remplissez les petites bouteilles pour
faire très court
ces deux étapes nécessite une des
homologations dit
de chacun des laboratoires qui les
produisent et vous avez des contrats de
sous traitance vous n'avez pas besoin
d'avoir un problème de propriété
intellectuelle je rappelle d'ailleurs
que sur astrazeneca c'est le sait oxford
qui a la propriété intellectuelle sur
baillons ntech cbo attaqué pape seither
donc à chaque fois il vous le voyez
d'ailleurs vous avez celui qui a conçu
le vaccin qui va ensuite chercher un
spécialiste de l'industrialisation pour
très vite montée en puissance lequel
spécialiste de l'industrialisation va
chercher des sous traitants qui ont des
sites homologué c'est pas la même chose
d'avoir un site homologué pour un virus
inactivé puisque c'est des laboratoires
p2 que d'avoir un arn ou vous avez des
spécificités et ensuite vous allez au
plus gros sites parce que le transfert
technologique prend autant de temps sur
un petit site ou sur un gros site
donc là le fait d'être très efficace
oblige aléas des gros sites et donc la
france sur certains axes 1 est
positionné sur la fabrication du
principe actif sur d'autres sur leur en
prit le remplissage des bouteilles et je
veux préciser une chose j mentionnait
récit farm delpharm fareva ce sont des
sous traitants ces trois sous traitants
vont fabriquer pour l'europe et
l'intelligence de la logistique va
probablement faire que ce sera plutôt
des doses qui rompt en france en
belgique fin au plus près de là où elles
sont produites mais ça c'est le
laboratoire pharmaceutique qui avoir
contractualisé qui organisera la
distribution en revanche c'est pas par
hasard qu'ils à cette production
c'est parce que nous avons lancé un
appel à projet au mois de juin avec
olivier ferrand pour précisément
permettent de renforcer nos capacités de
production de médicaments utilisés dans
le cadre du mali seront la lutte contre
la corrida ou pour des potentiels
candidats vaccins que aujourd'hui vous
avez deux de ses laboratoires de ses
sous-traitants delpharm et fareva qui
bénéficient d'un soutien public pour
accélérer la production et le troisième
a déposé également un dossier qui est en
cours d'instruction
j'espère que c'est plus clair comme ça
très bien je n'aurais pas un peu plus
complètement à la question de maurice
tic de monsieur
monsieur morel pour vous dire à toutes
et à tous et en étant début d'année
cette crise
dis moi on va bien qu'on gère
malheureusement quelque chose qui s'est
installé dans la durée qu'on n'aurait
pas prévu certainement pas voulu donc il
faut gérer ce temps long vous avez
observé que j'ai volontairement fait un
point précis sur la stratégie test est
allé alerter protéger parce que je pense
qu'elle va continuer à être appliquée
encore pendant quelques mois parce
qu'elle sera très utile et je défère
donnant un maximum de données que vous
pouvez vérifier sur le déploiement de
cette stratégie
qu'est-ce qu'elles démontrent non pas
qu'il n'y a pas eu de difficultés
auxquelles peu de problèmes il y en a eu
comme dans tous les pays mais qu' elle
est sans doute l'une des plus
performantes d'europe
nous testons le plus avec des délais en
moyenne est plus court on sait encore où
sont nos marges de progrès on va mettre
le moyen les moyens dessus notamment sur
l'effectivité de l' isolement
mais c'est une stratégie qui s'est
déployée de manière satisfaisante
et pourtant et pourtant avant le
soi-disant échec des vaccins on lit
partout comme si c'était une doll est
d'évidence les tests ça marche pas mais
c'est faux mais c'est faux j'ai encore
une fois il ya des problèmes bien des
difficultés
mais quand je compare avec les autres
unités sont gratuites et stores rapide
les testons sur en france l'assurance
maladie déploient des moyens
considérables pour assurer le traçage
l'application tout senti qu vide
après quelques difficultés démarrage a
progressé de manière significative
voilà donc tout ça s'inscrit dans la
durée vous avez raison selon elle il
faut penser que c'est aussi la durée le
sérieux que nous administrons dans le
déploiement des vaccins qui renforceront
l'adhésion de nos concitoyens le vrai
test en fait bien
c'est celui comme il y en a combien
nerveux connais beaucoup le vrai test
c'est parmi les populations dans votre
ehpad madame qu'on va vacciner chez les
plus de 75 ans demain chez les soignants
aujourd'hui quel est le pourcentage de
ceux qui se feront effectivement matinée
c'est ça le défi collectif
c'est ça le défi est donc voilà nous
devons j'ai employé l'expression ne pas
confondre vitesse et précipitation
répondre à ceux qui veulent qu'on les
vaccine c'est notre devoir c'est pas
d'entrevoir c'est notre objectif mais
aussi parce qu'on fait pas les choses
d'un porte comment parce qu'on ne croise
pas le consentement des gens parce qu'on
respecte les considérations éthiques
suscitées le plus d'adhésions possible
c'est ça aussi une stratégie vaccinale
ce n'est pas mais vous le savez
parfaitement qu'une question logistique
c'est une question de logistique majeur
bien entendu mais c'est aussi une
question psychologique parce que là
succès de cette stratégie vaccinale
repose adhésion surtout de ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin pour eux mêmes et
pour protéger les autres le système
hospitalier et je ne vous apprendrai pas
aux uns comme aux autres que nous sommes
un pays bien avant l'arrivée de l'aco
vide où l'engouement dont les vaccins
n'est pas parmi les plus développés
effectivement vous avez raison
finalement là je vois que ya un certain
nombre de personnes qui interviennent en
parlant des vaccins avec une forme
d'appétit qui me réjouit on va leur
donner satisfaction
allez on va prendre encore une ou deux
questions bon sens l'esprit ministre
peureux briac agence france presse afp
d'abord une précision vous avez dit ce
soir kilrea frontière avec le royaume
uni est resté fermé qu'est ce que ça
veut dire précisément ça veut dire que
c'est le statu quo ou au contraire que
des mesures plus restrictives à être
mise en place est une deuxième question
mi décembre devant le parlement
il avait indiqué qu'un million 800 mille
doses seraient disponibles en france ou
vers le 6 janvier
nous y sommes manifestement ces doses ne
sont pas là alors est ce que c'est un
problème de production industrielle ou
est ce que c'est un problème de
logistique de stockage en france qui
explique que cette promesse n'a pas été
tenue
merci donc à nouveau merci de faire
venir à notre ministre au pupitre pour
cette histoire de doses j'ai déjà vu
cette question mais on va vous répondre
pour la grande bretagne en clair donc
pour l'instant je réponds ça sent très
précis c'est le statu quo je parle sous
le contrôle des gens spécialisés on a dû
reprendre un décret parce que les
mesures de fermeture qu'on avait pris
s'achever le 6 monsieur c'est ça donc on
les a prolongées oui c'est le statu quo
donc les frontières sont fermées et pour
les les citoyens français qui réside en
grande bretagne est pur il ya surtout à
fait c'est surtout le premier routier à
un test au départ dont le présent la
république nous devons lui faire rapport
a demandé à ce que soient bien évaluer
les modalités d'application de ces
dispositions de mesurer aussi c'était le
sans intervention du ministre de la
santé les l'impact des informations
scientifiques que nous disposons au fur
et à mesure chaque jour davantage sur ce
virus mutant aussi je pense je parle son
contrôle qu'un avis du conseil
scientifique sur ce sujet précis est
attendu pour le début de la semaine
prochaine
mardi je crois et donc nous pourrions
être amenés à prendre des mesures
soyons clairs certainement pas dans
l'allègement du dispositif
certainement pas alors sur les fameux
1,8 million de doses madame la ministre
je crois que c'était la fin du mois de
janvier
donc ça recoupe les chiffres qu'on vient
de vous donner ce qui avait été dit au
mois de décembre et nous sommes comme
l'a très bien indiqué monsieur le
ministre de la santé à 560 mille doses
livrées chaque semaine donc on sera tout
à fait dans c'est
niveau donc c'est nier un problème
industriel isation n'est un problème de
pardon de logistique c'est tout
simplement une question de compréhension
de nos tableaux probablement voilà une
dernière question madame délai
d'injection entre les deux doses la
deuxième dose le laboratoire pfizer
avait dit qu'il préférait pas qu'on
reporte au delà de trois semaines vous
dites que vous allez reporté jusqu'à six
semaines
est-ce que c'est pas tout dangereux pour
l'efficacité du vaccin qui vous donne
l'autorisation vous parlez des autorités
sanitaires est ce que c'est la nsm la
haute autorité de santé
et justement est-ce que c'est pas plus
dangereux de reporter en tout cas c'est
moins efficace pour le vaccin de
reporter la deuxième dose est comment
allez-vous faire justement pour gérer
les douze là-dessus ce point là a en
tout cas monsieur biya sera t il y aura
bien une deuxième injection
parce que vous auriez pu aussi posé
cette question par rapport à des
pratiques de pays amis je ne peux pas
croire que vous puissiez croire qu'on
prendrait une décision qui serait
dangereuse on qui conduirait être moins
efficace vu tout ce qu'on fait pour
organiser la stratégie vaccinale le pays
c'est qu'on a envie que ça serve c'est
pas pour le plaisir d'injection c'est
pour que ça puisse être efficace et
protéger les français
non ce qui est relève des informations
et scientifique ont eu c'est que ça ne
peut pas la deuxième injection de rappel
ne peut pas avoir lieu moins de 21 jours
moins de trois semaines avant la moins
de trois semaines après la première
injection
sinon là on a une perte d'efficacité
c'était ce qui relevait de l'étude et
ensuite ils ont observé c'est qu'il ya
des patients etc dans le cadre du
protocole et dans le cas des de la
vaccination qui ont une injection plus
tardive que les trois semaines et même
certains ont une injection beaucoup plus
tardif que les trois semaines et ça
s'est très bien passé donc les données
dont nous disposons et évidemment on ne
fait pas ça sans l'avis conforme des
autorités sanitaires en l'occurrence la
rsm je ne sais plus si la chasse la
haute autorité de santé a eu à se
prononcer mais tout est parfaitement
conforme et si je vous l'annoncé qu' on
est back et de ce point de vue là des
peut parler par les scientifiques et les
acteurs de la santé
merci beaucoup et à bientôt ah je vous
ai déjà répondu à cette question
j'ai déjà répondu à cette question donc
dès que j'espère je me ferai vacciner
je souhaite ardemment me faire vacciner
je le saurai quand mon tour viendra
voilà merci beaucoup